[Musique]
youtube s'est excusé on se retrouve
aujourd'hui compagnie de lucas den
broeck celle pour le retourner défilé
squeeze alors dans cette petite vidéo
vous devez vous demander quel va être le
concept à chaque mort est bien ce sera
pas chaque mois on met toutes les deux
trois morts et en fait on va se prendre
une grosse tarte alors à la framboise de
chocolat ou alors à l'ao caramélisées
dans la gueule voilà donc tous les 2-3
qu'il sait où qui s'entraînent une et
toutes les deux trois morts c'est moi
qui m'en prendre une
vous verrez que l'étape ne seront pas
mis simplement en courant dans la gueule
hu a bercé regarde pas concentre-toi
l'intégration et jeu concentré jusqu'au
ça allait y aller non là c'est la
prochaine fois que je meurs wolin
compris les gens des gens sont en retard
bon les gars attendait parce que là ça
risque d'être très distant mais j'ai
trop nul j'ai trop dit majeur op
allez vite qui va se faire une tarte en
cours nos wii sont oui alors je sais pas
qui c'est ça va être sur une tarte ou
pas mais en tout cas chez qu'on va bien
rire allons gossip girl
non
[Musique]
ce sera pour lui cassera pour la ta
réponse pour le déchet pour les déchets
allez hop on continue ou rush on n'a pas
peur on est d'aider olona au nom non
mais les assistances on peut compter
disait aimer ça fait de me taire
[ __ ] non mais les gars les cadettes
ont craqué a été cracké c'est pas parce
qu'ils jouent mal ou quoi et que bon
voilà c'est un faux rythme
c'est pas lui
oui c'est pareil c'est la fête
les tartes elles vont pleuvoir mon gars
moi je te le dis allez au revoir
monsieur à bientôt à nous ça risque
d'être assez épique vous allez voir un
ouais
[Musique]
je n'en dis pas plus ouais ça se trouve
ils ont déjà vu de manière spéciale
ouais c'est plutôt spécial mois alors
heureusement fort elle même parce que si
on aurait fait en 2000 je pense que on
serait pris environ 30 cartes chacun tu
veux bien que déjà les tartes c'est ce
que relate alors qu'on a acheté de 15
fils de chien voilà amélie sont pas tant
les défis sont contents on voit des
lumières dans leurs yeux tu t'es un
[ __ ] je veux apprendre certains dans
x ray ban
[Musique]
les anciennes sont serrés les gens à
camper dans la maison mais regarde le
mont gammée
[Rires]
alors concentré ça c'est drôle alors
vous les gars est-ce que vous jouez
souvent un colloque on va parler un peu
de collègues en fait jamais sur ma
chaîne est ce que vous êtes un petit peu
des pros call of ou pas on lui qu'à toi
toi qui t'es ok si nul encore qui fait
forcément donc seuls en dehors mois
colosse foyer jouer un petit peu mais
blackhawks 2 joue plus trop parce que je
me suis lassé ouais en fait lucas il est
mauvais à cologne avec la fille
à
voilà on essaie 0 a été arrêté pour
métro petit screenshot
voyez les scores de l'ue qu'assure fifa
bon vous allez vous avez bien qu'il faut
dire que je lui aussi battu ce maxime
[Musique]
après la bouée faut l'avouer - monde
dans laquelle thank you can c'est clair
bon les gars en fin de ce carnage là ou
quoi ben alors les gars
à
[Musique]
je crois qu'on va se prendre de la tarte
dans la gueule mais alors les gars ça
sent la tarte tatin
si on pouvait sentir la chantilly l'un
avec un droit mais attends attends
attends ils sont potes l'état mais alors
moment il conduit la moto n'était pas
son nom mais je prends désormais en
rouge avoue l'image originale et non
mais t'as vu composition spéciale au fil
de votre promenade
heureusement que tu es devant le cas
puisqu'il touche que parce qu'on
voudrait alors on va utiliser le web
bientôt film attention les derniers qui
vont avec tumeur tant que voilà les
dernières tarte pour qui je suis déjà
ses membres pour qu'ils aient du temps
[Musique]
cela faisait quoi tes massamba par
contre je crois qu'on va autant on va se
prendre le temps de tarte vous que moi
apparemment les gars voulaient
[Musique]
d'accord lui il est passé d'un pont
couvert
non mais regardez les attendait si on
part sur une victoire on se lève et on
danse la macarena les gains j'annonce au
regard des comptes avait bien rigolé en
voyant des tartes des filets comme ça le
score ces deux de 15 à 13 donc on va
faire tout les deux textes semblent donc
je me suis pris cette tarte et vous vous
êtes blessé sans procès tais toi t'es
mort 13 fois en 13 départs de
s'affaisser
en tout cas se trouvent deux là dedans
une nouvelle vidéo n'hésite pas aimé la
vidéo si tu veux plus de défis de
squeeze on est parti pour une nouvelle
saison il y aura quatre épisodes avec
trois molosses mois se retrouve bientôt
et le prochaine épisode should be nice
et bientôt his office de steve wallace
nickel